oh Que honra estar nesse tapete mágico
das ideias que merecem ser espalhadas e
a minha missão aqui é te mostrar como é
que e porque nós estamos na era da
integridade nessa transição que através
dos valores princípios e Virtudes e da
busca por consciência nos leva para
única forma de evolução da humanidade
e nós estamos num momento somos homo
sapiens sapiens né o ser humano que sabe
e que sabe que sabe devemos Essa era do
conhecimento a gente quase que imita a
arte né naquele filme do Star Wars e
cada um de nós nada com o Android alguns
de Oeste ali que nos dá acesso a uma
infinidade de informações
Oi e um grande paradoxo nessa área do
conhecimento nós estamos também vivendo
a maior crise de saúde mental da
humanidade depressão ansiedade bournout
o e inclusive suicídio Entrando nos
noticiários e nas famílias e pior a
gente não sabe muito bem o que fazer com
isso
e esse quase paradoxo nos coloca numa
reflexão porque a humanidade hoje já
consegue prever a sua chegada em Marte
mas a Curta viagem entre a nossa mente
eo nosso coração foi feita por bem
poucos como o brilhantemente e mostrou o
Carlos Drummond de Andrade no poema o
homem as viagens
e esse momento que nós temos nos traz
uma reflexão
é porque essa busca fora nos causa
grande falta de sentido e de significado
E aí isso se manifesta entre também
entre vários fatores por exemplo numa
insatisfação com a vida profissional com
o trabalho não descompasso entre
propósito pessoal e propósito nas
empresas onde as pessoas trabalham
Esse é o do termo Home Office né então
utilizado agora na pandemia quase que
ganhou o seu significado real porque a
gente conseguiu olhar esses dois lados e
nos incêndio uma reflexão
não é possível separar vida pessoal de
vida profissional é possível separar as
emoções do pensamento é possível separar
alguma coisa É possível viver nessa
ilusória separação em que vivemos
E olha que interessante para gerar
energia elétrica precisamos da União das
polaridades positiva e negativa para
gerar uma nova vida é necessária a união
do masculino e do feminino para observar
mos a luz precisamos o contraste da
sombra e até para compreender o bem é
necessário a observação do mal
bom E nós como humanidade já temos o
conhecimento e tecnologia para resolver
todos os nossos problemas o que fizemos
agora com a crise do convívio os
governos os cientistas e as pessoas de
maneira focada conseguimos demonstrar
que quando queremos a humanidade é capaz
de acelerar rapidamente para o solução
daquilo que está acontecendo e neste
momento né os problemas de alteração
climática e todas as consequências para
o planeta que já existiam antes nos
colocam uma posição de maior urgência
para tomada de decisões e mudanças
e já cultura de valores aponta a solução
fazer o que é certo porque é certo fazer
o que é certo porque as consequências
que vão gerar são positivas essa escolha
consciente da integridade porque
integridade é remete a perfeição ao
completo ao perfeito a palavra
integridade a sua origem do latim vende
Inter o inteiro o todo completo e essa
palavra Ela também tem um contexto
matemático da junção da união de todas
as polaridades é a integridade que traz
a união porque ela é o todo o completo O
100 porcento o presente e aí até a
matemática nos já deixou pistas o
princípio da integridade hoop né o
é que para criar um círculo de diâmetro
perfeito tamanho de um já deixou essa
pista nos mostrando que é através do
princípio da integridade que a gente
chega a perfeição
Oi e a busca pela integridade sempre fui
uma questão natural ao ser humano
o Adam Smith antes de escrever sobre
economia em 1759 publicou um livro
chamado teoria dos princípios Morais e
lá ele postulou que o ser humano não
quer repetir a dor eo sofrimento para si
próprio e por empatia tampouco para o
seu semelhante demonstrando que a busca
de valores morais é natural ao ser
humano e por isso para se ser é a forma
menos dolorosa e de Menor sofrimento
para nossa evolução a jornada individual
de Ascensão da consciência é
praticamente uma jornada de herói e pode
ser também chamada de caminho da
integridade e o primeiro passo dessa
jornada desse caminho da integridade é a
auto-observação e Como disse o filósofo
Estefano Dana auto-observação é auto
correção
bom E se a gente quer olhar a
autocorreção EA auto-observação e níveis
Gerais a gente também quer construir uma
sociedade mais próximo da integridade a
gente vai precisar de líderes de pessoas
de governos mais íntegros e para a gente
ter líderes mais íntegros nós precisamos
de seres humanos conscientes hoje nós já
temos condições de olhar para várias
tecnologias e conhecimentos que nos
mostram que esse sonho EA Utopia são
Possivelmente realizáveis
e realizáveis por o conhecimento que
vieram aqui no palco do Ted inclusive
como por exemplo as blusones são
exemplos no mundo inteiro de que é
possível viver em harmonia e em completa
integridade juntando tudo que há de
melhor como também o exemplo Brasil
biais ao o conceito de renda Universal
básica como também a correlação entre
confiança e as cidades mais felizes do
mundo as também bcob as empresas que
buscam fazer algo de bom para o mundo
como propósito e em especial a
tecnologia Creeper que nos colocou
condições atuais da humanidade poder
editar o seu próprio código genético
e pela primeira vez na história temos
condições de criar alterar as
características que nós queremos para
nossa própria evolução E aí ficar
pergunta que características nós teremos
para essa próxima espécie humana
e eu não tenho dúvida que nós queremos
escolher baseados naquilo que nós já
sabemos por exemplo a gente sabe que
ganância preconceito desrespeito com o
meio ambiente é preconceitos também
raciais geram coisas negativas Assim
como nós sabemos que valores absolutos
como a confiança a verdade a honestidade
a colaboração e o respeito geram
resultados positivos essa escolha já é
fácil de ser tomada quando a gente tem
uma cultura de valores que Embasa a
nossa decisão essa consciência então de
que espécie que queremos fazer eu me
arrisco a dizer que essa nova espécie
vai ser chamada de homo cônscios humano
que é consciente de si e consciente do
seu papel no coletivo também consciên
e na sociedade e no planeta porque essa
consciência que nos leva para era da
integridade Essa era que não mais como
em outros momentos da história se deu a
mudança de era por algo e ou algum fato
externo ao ser mas que nesse momento
depende única e exclusivamente de uma
decisão consciente do indivíduo então eu
faço pegando a deixa de Gandhi mas me
colocando além da mudança fazendo essa
proposta Eu proponho que você e eu
sejamos o ser humano que queremos ver no
mundo porque essa é então a era da
integridade e do homo com seus Muito
obrigado
E aí